Seinfeld would have been a lot different with
another actress playing Elaine, and that’s
what would have happened if Julia Louis-Dreyfus
had decided to live the life of an heiress
rather than pursue acting.
And that wasn’t out of the realm of possibility.
Julia’s father is multi-billionaire Gerard
Louis-Dreyfus and her family tree is littered
with extremely wealthy and successful (in
business) individuals going back over a century-
as such Julia probably didn’t need to work
a day in her life.
You wouldn’t know it from listening to her,
though.
In an interview conducted on the Howard Stern
Show in 2003, Julia denied that she was brought
up “rich” and didn’t need to worry about
money, saying:
No, my father’s not a billionaire.
And I work mainly for money…
[My dad runs] this company in France called
the Louis-Dreyfus Corporation.
It’s a company that does well, but it isn’t
the Dreyfus Fund.
While it’s true that the company isn’t
the “Dreyfus Fund,” today Forbes estimates
Gerard’s net worth at $3.2 billion.
The company was founded by Julia’s great-great-grandfather,
Léopold Louis-Dreyfus, in 1851, so the business
has been kept in the family for generations.
Of course, she might not have been “raised
rich” all the same—at least not billionaire
rich.
Julia was born in 1961, and just a year later
her parents divorced.
The separation undoubtedly caused some splitting
of the family’s assets.
Further, the family fortune, which at one
time was called one of “the five greatest
fortunes in France” was diminished quite
a bit due to WWII.
However, it’s something of an understatement
to only say the “company does well.”
Today, the Louis-Dreyfus Group has about $120
billion in gross annual sales, and is estimated
to be worth about $46 billion.
“Well” indeed.
Besides Julia’s father doing OK for himself,
her now deceased cousin, Robert Louis-Dreyfus
was at one point the CEO of Adidas and was
extremely successful in his own right in various
business ventures.
His wife inherited that branch of the family
fortune in 2009, also taking over management
of her husband’s various companies, and
today she is considered to be the wealthiest
woman in Russia, with a net-worth of about
$6 billion.
On top of that, there are several other members
of the Louis-Dreyfus family tree, descended
from Léopold Louis-Dreyfus, that have similar
accomplishments in the business world.
One can only imagine what their family reunions
are like.
That said, Julia is a successful, wealthy
actress in her own right.
She certainly earned the respect of her father
for making her own way in the world rather
than depending on the family fortune.
In the last few years of Seinfeld, she was
earning $600,000 per episode.
But Julia started off acting in relatively
humble beginnings—as a theatre student at
Northwestern University.
After she finished her education there, she
became involved in the Practical Theatre Company
in Chicago, which her husband had helped to
start.
She also worked as part of the Second City
comedy troupe.
Afterwards, she auditioned for Saturday Night
Live, which she was on from 1982-1985.
Following that, she was cast in a couple of
sitcoms and starred in two Woody Allen films
before
her big break: Seinfeld.